all right sopranos fans rejoice but
first this portion of the video is
sponsored by hamilton watchers more
specifically their hamilton khaki field
far cry 6 limited edition watch featured
in the game far cry 6. in the game the
watch gives you better defense while
sprinting in the real world it gives you
an amazing conversation starter and a
quality timepiece it's an automatic
watch so no batteries needed it's
powered by motion and speaking on the
style i love the fact that it doesn't
feel like a watch from a video game the
watch in the video game feels like a
watch in the real world because it is it
helps the world of the game feel more
real and helps you appreciate the
quality of the timepiece itself and
hamilton watches have been a favorite of
filmmakers for decades their watches
have appeared in over 500 feature films
custom pieces playing a pivotal role in
the men in black franchise tenet
interstellar jack ryan cinephile watch
that's for sure it's a limited edition
watch there are only 1983 of these
timepieces being made so click the link
below visit the hamilton watch website
discover this quality timepiece again
that portion of the video is sponsored
by hamilton watches and now on to the
review
so the many saints of newark is a
sopranos prequel movie i say that with
my own prequel movie tone because it
does its part to stand as its own film
it largely follows dickie maltasanti
who's the father of christopher
maltasanti from the soprano show follows
the goings-on of him and his family as
well as some tension rising in the world
of crime also racial tensions rising in
the area and the time alessandro nivola
who plays dickie moltasante the movie
largely rests on his shoulders yeah it
being a crime movie of sopranos world
movie uh there are a lot of support
characters who also have a big role and
a big part to play and how the movie all
comes together but he's the star he's
the main character i thought he was
great in the movie he's electrifying
he's magnetic he's charismatic you kind
of feel for the guy it the movie all
right well this is my big confession i
haven't seen the sopranos i planned on
catching up on the series before this
movie came out i got through season one
really enjoyed it like i got through
season one sounds negative i don't mean
it that way but i watched season one
wanted to watch more but then life
things happened and it kind of set me
back on that but what i really
appreciated about the sopranos is a
thing that i thought they nailed in here
in terms of oh yeah that's from the show
which is this world's ability to go from
all right family drama crime they never
hide that but you know you get to the
point where you're empathizing with some
characters you're like you know there
there are some good people and oh my god
that was horrifically violent the movie
does what the show does which is get you
to the point where you forget that these
are
hardened gangsters and criminals who are
capable of doing really horrific things
to people and also there are some
standout performances in here vera
farmiga plays tony soprano's mother
which even in season one you're like is
she just a cranky old lady or is she
emotionally manipulative
and an and yeah you even get
that in the trailer where the school
administrator whoever is like oh your
son he's really smart she's like
rolls her eyes i thought she was great
also ray leota's in this movie which at
first i just appreciated the fact that
ray liotta's in this mob movie and it's
kind of hard to talk about his character
and who he plays but at first he didn't
really stand out to me but then at a
point in this movie ray leota steals the
scenes he's in he's a man of few words
but he's more of a presence he's the
person in this movie he's probably the
smartest and wisest of all the people in
the movie and he got to that point
because of the life he's lived because
he has learned from the mistakes he's
made he's a man who just accepts the
reality of his situation i just i loved
him also young tony soprano who i didn't
know was james gandalfini's son playing
him but when i saw the trailer i was
like
that's his son or his clone pick one
james gandolfini in the limited amount
of the sopranos that i have seen is
undeniably incredible on that show i
thought michael gandalfini i mean those
are some big shoes for him to fill i
just thought he was really good in the
movie and i thought the movie was also
really good for tony soprano's character
it would have been so easy for it to
revolve around tony soprano but he's not
in the game yet at this point in his
life so it really wouldn't be a mob
movie it wouldn't be as interesting it's
better to have tony soprano be a support
character in here and kind of show
the way he kind of gets interested in
this world it also makes it feel much
more real you know it's like tony
soprano became tony soprano
but he didn't mean to it's not like the
world was just parting the shoes like
hello tony soprano we have table right
here waiting for you because you're
special and because this is your life
for most of us out there if a movie was
made about our lives it'd either be
boring or you'd have to concentrate on a
more interesting element that's around
your life in which you would be a
supporting character that's just the
harsh reality of life and it feels more
special the fact that he becomes much
bigger in his adult life than he ever
expected to be i thought that was a
smart play on the movies part make tony
soprano one piece but a larger picture
at hand leslie odom jr in this movie is
also on the rise it but that's the part
where i'm like i don't feel resolution
with that arc and that's where as much
as i feel like it's an advantageous
thing for me to watch this movie from
the eyes of someone who really hasn't
seen the sopranos it's a good metric to
be like do i have to have watched
sopranos in order to enjoy this movie or
not um i don't know if there's
resolution with that arc in the series
and largely i felt like the movie
abruptly did end it was just like oh and
it's over
okay it leaves it open for like a sequel
could happen that concentrates more
around tony soprano sure or it's a
one-off that completely abruptly ends
you just pick up years later where tony
soprano was tony soprano but i have my
answer now do you need to watch the
soprano series in order to enjoy this
movie i don't think so no i didn't this
movie does its part to be its own
compelling mob story it has easter eggs
and references that you will recognize
if you have seen the series also there's
a spoiler at the beginning of this movie
so there's that i was watching i was
like oh so all right well i have that
answer my own fault i should have
watched it before now but it's a movie
if you love mob movies you can enjoy
this movie just on its own merits and if
you love the sopranos you'll get more
out of it absolutely and for nothing
else i'm interested to watch the entire
series of the sopranos then watch this
movie again and experience it completely
differently there's something cool about
that i like that i had a really great
time with this movie no alcohol required
all right so the many saints of newark
have you seen it are you gonna see it
are you looking forward to it are you
soprano super fan whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you